[Music]
on this Wednesday night the exit
strategy for Canadians in Wuhan China it
was like being on a Walking Dead episode
Ottawa's planned to send a plane as
cases in China accelerate and racism
spreads along with the virus their
colleague at work went around asking
everyone who has Asian are you from
China and it was very inappropriate
Global News exclusive Canada is a
perfect tool under math how the
crackdown on bc's dirty money could be
spawning problems elsewhere plus love
from Canada to Australia help animals
don't I sell fake plants our disaster
ignited heartwarming gestures
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the impact the new
corona virus is having on families and
businesses as that virus continues to
spread entire cities in China have now
virtually shut down not just in who Bay
province the epicenter of the outbreak
but across mainland China Canada today
upgraded its Travel Warning advising
Canadians to avoid all non-essential
travel to all of mainland China and Air
Canada today suspended direct flights to
the mainland the government has now
organized a charter flight to bring home
Canadians caught in the lockdown in
Wuhan there's no clarity though on when
that will happen or where those people
will go part of the process now is
figuring out exactly what our protocols
will be when we return Canadians that
wish to come home and we're working very
closely with our US counterparts who
obviously have some experience in this a
charter flight carrying more than 200
American citizens airlifted out of Wuhan
touched down at an air base in
California today health officials have
asked them to voluntarily quarantine
themselves for three days at least five
people on board an evacuation flight to
Japan have been hospitalized and are
undergoing tests and the UK is making
plans to fly some of its citizens home
from Wuhan they'll be quarantined for 14
days
Australia plans to fly as many 600 of
its citizens out and quarantine them for
up to two weeks on Christmas Island more
than 1500 kilometres away from the
Australian coast at the site of an
immigration detention center more than
70 100 cases have now been confirmed in
China an increase of over a thousand
compared to yesterday and there are
thousands more suspected cases 170
people have now died there are more
people sick in China now with the new
coronavirus than became ill with SARS in
China in 2003 though fewer people have
died that rapid acceleration has led the
World Health Organization to reconvene
its Emergency Committee tomorrow it will
determine whether to declare a global
public health emergency I believe that
the world is pulling together to respond
to this outbreak we are at an important
juncture in this event
we as whu-oh believe that this these
chains of transmission can still be
interrupted and that remains the hope
but right now Canada is ramping up plans
to get about a hundred and sixty
Canadians out of the Wuhan area
Abigail Beeman has been talking to some
of them and has our top story tonight we
get up in the morning we brush our teeth
routine is key for Canadian Wayne do
plus C and his family as they spend most
of their days inside their Wuhan
apartment it was like being on a Walking
Dead episode there's no one around and
you're used to things being a little
quiet because all the bikes are electric
and all the motorcycles are electric so
you use the things kind of coming up on
you I turn a corner and boom there's
like 20 people in masks we have a lot of
food stocked up because of Chinese New
Year and family members not coming here
since the breakout so generally we know
nobody in the house goes outside
Vancouver right Patterson Wu was
visiting his girlfriend's family in
Wuhan when the outbreak began he says
entertaining himself is easier than
staying positive as the number of sick
grows and he wants Canada to do more
we're supposed to be one of the most
modern countries in the world and it's
kind of sad to see like you know Koreans
and Japanese they all mobilize so fast
America but we're so slow I would
disagree with you in Ottawa the Foreign
Affairs Minister pushed back on the
claim Canada is slow as he announced
Wednesday afternoon that a plane has
been secured to get the 160 Canadians in
China who want help out Canada is at the
forefront of the response we are talking
with the allies and it's not an easy
decision but we've decided to stay put
du plus C is concerned about the
potential of picking up the virus on the
plane though he's worried about getting
sick in China too one of the discussions
that I had with Emily my wife is about
sharing passwords you know to our bank
accounts and
PayPal that sort of thing with our
daughter who's in Indonesia and if worse
came to worse and we were no longer here
as of Wednesday afternoon Canada updated
its travel advisory to China warning
against all non-essential travel but
there are still many unanswered
questions such as when the plane will
arrive what happens to the people on
board once they land and who pays the
bill
Abigail Beeman Global News Ottawa the
vast majority of confirmed cases are in
China but one thing that's not clear yet
is whether China's attempt to contain
the virus is working and whether people
without symptoms can infect others that
will make containing this much harder
the number of other countries with
confirmed cases now of the new
coronaviruses rising at least 18
countries and territories are reporting
it Finland has confirmed its first case
and the United Arab Emirates has also
confirmed a case the first in the Middle
East at a Eurex West looks at the global
response how quickly this virus is
spreading outside of China may prompt
the World Health Organization to finally
declare the outbreak an international
health emergency although the numbers
outside China are still relatively small
they hold the potential for a much
larger outbreak the World Health
Organization says at least six cases of
the disease have now been transmitted
outside China in Germany four people
have become ill after a woman with no
symptoms traveled from China for
business meetings
she was asymptomatic on arrival but
became ill shortly before taking her
return flight while there are still
questions around how this new strain of
the corona virus spreads most cases have
required prolonged close contact with
someone who is already ill a symptomatic
transmission isn't impossible but this
would be breaking the mold right if
suddenly a symptomatic transmission was
a big way of the spreading around the
world and biologically it doesn't make
sense
Canada's third case of the disease a BC
man in his 40s has now been confirmed
Ontario has two confirmed cases and
Wednesday morning Ontario health
officials were testing 23 others four
people are also being tested in
Saskatchewan I think we need to be
reassured that from the three cases
reported in Canada and other
jurisdictions in two instances the
person the confirmed cases are well
enough to self isolate at home but the
World Health Organization says all
countries need to remain vigilant as the
number of sick continues to rise
worldwide Heather your ex west Global
News to Calgary weeks into this and
there's still no formal name for the
corona virus we'll tell you what goes
into naming a new virus at Global News
CA / global national Global News has
reported extensively on the police
investigation and cracked down into
money laundering and organized crime at
BC casinos now we've obtained exclusive
new information about Ontario casinos
documents obtained by Global News
revealed a number of investigations into
suspicious cash in Ontario casinos more
than doubled in 2018 experts say
international drug cartels that targeted
BC to wash their dirty money have now
shifted their focus east my quick a tour
has this exclusive story it was a simple
scheme used by criminal organizations to
launder money through Vancouver casinos
someone would come in with duffel bags
full of cash gamble a little and then
cash out and leave with clean money a BC
did roll out new laws to crack down on
so-called suspicious transactions
flowing through casinos but there's
concern the problem has moved East to
Ontario according to data obtained
exclusively by Global News the number of
suspicious transaction investigations in
Ontario casinos has more than doubled
since 2018 which happens to be the same
year BC crackdown on money laundering at
casinos there are we concerned about
people from other jurisdictions coming
here and to try and infiltrate our
casinos absolutely still the head of the
casino investigation unit with the
Ontario Provincial Police says the spike
in the number of suspicious transactions
is a result of better training and
better scrutiny he also blames the
increase
on a recent shift in games available at
some casinos you turn a slot facility
into a full-blown casino with table
games there's larger transactions that
automatically occur that should generate
suspicious transaction reports with
being organized crime experts say it's a
nationwide issue Canada is a perfect
laundromat and we don't do anything to
remove that label everyone in the world
knows that Canada has a lower risk of a
prosecution and attention than any other
country in the world Antonio New Castle
says every major criminal organization
has a branch in Canada for that reason
police allege Angelo figlio MANET and
nearly two dozen others linked to the
Italian mafia have laundered roughly
seventy million dollars through Ontario
casinos in a two year period the charges
filio many faces include directing a
criminal organization and possessing
proceeds of crime the allegations have
not been proven in court
it's believed it was done in 30 to 50
thousand dollar chunks split among
multiple players if you only gamble a
small amount cash out leave the casino
that looks like casino winnings so you
leave there under the guise of
successful play and you've essentially
laundered some funds while law
enforcement believes they are making
strides because they're tracking more of
these suspicious transactions organized
crime experts say nothing is being done
to deter the practice according to
statistics Canada between the year 2000
and 2016 three quarters of people
charged with money laundering walked
free michael accretor global news Ottawa
there's a call for sweeping changes to
Canada's broadcasting and
telecommunications sector the federal
government asked a panel to consider
everything from the role of Netflix to
mobile phone and Internet services and
the future of the CBC after 18 months of
consultations it's come up with 97
recommendations it's a lot to digest our
day-to-day can break sit down for us
David well Donna this proposed rewrite
of Canada's media and telecom
regulations starts with a basic idea
that one rule ought to apply to
all companies providing media content to
Canadian audiences regardless of the
platform regardless of their country of
origin and that basic idea would have
the biggest impact on popular digital
services not based in Canada think
Netflix Disney Spotify YouTube or Apple
TV Plus first they'd all start
collecting GST or HST on the monthly
subscriptions paid by their Canadian
customers just like any Canadian media
company and those foreign web giant's
would also kick in a percentage of the
revenue they earn in Canada into a
special fund to help create more
Canadian content that's something
Canadian media companies like Global's
parent company chorus already does
contributing hundreds of millions of
dollars a year to a Canadian media fund
if you benefit from operating in the
Canadian system you should contribute
it's a simple principle but will this
cost consumers more so we do not think
that this is something that would be
passed on to consumers or result in
higher prices the panel also believes it
is unfair to private sector media
companies that the CBC should be able to
sell advertising while it gets a federal
subsidy of more than 1 billion dollars a
year so the panel is telling the
government to force CBC to go ad free
supervising all of these changes would
be a new super regulator a CRTC on
steroids that would have sweeping powers
to poke its nose into everything from
the price of home internet service to
writing up codes of conduct for news
organizations our goal is simple to make
the system more equitable than it is
right now the technological changes that
we have seen have made it so that our
system doesn't work anymore and the
government is promising to act quickly
to table some new legislation within the
year but already there are some concerns
that some of the panel's recommendations
may violate some international trade
agreements like the new NAFTA and some
might even violate the Canadian Charter
of Rights and Freedoms Donna all right
David akin in Ottawa thanks it is over
except for the final goodbye the
European Parliament is overwhelmingly
back the terms of the UK's departure
from the EU
[Music]
em if he's marked the moment by singing
auld lang syne some said they hope the
UK would return one day
others warned Britain not to seek too
many advantages in future trade talks
and Nigel Farage who is pushed for
brexit for years waved a little Union
Jack flag until his microphone was cut
off I know you want to ban our national
flags but we're gonna wave you goodbye
and we'll look forward in the future to
working with you as sovereign the
vice-president of the European
Parliament told him put your flags away
you're leaving and take them with you
the UK officially departs on Friday two
dead satellites on a collision course
coming up the risky situation
astronomers are keeping a close eye on
we're getting a clearer picture tonight
of just how much the grounding of
Boeing's entire fleet of 737 max jets
could cost the company the tab is
expected to surpass eighteen billion
dollars u.s. that's roughly double what
was estimated costs include compensating
Airlines and customers reopening the 737
max factory and the sharp rise in costs
to produce the plane again
the company also revealed today at lost
636 million dollars last year its first
annual loss since 1997 there's no exact
timeline for when the max series jets
will be cleared for flight boeing is
hopeful regulators will approve approve
a software update by mid 2020 the best
selling aircraft was grounded last march
after crashes in indonesia and ethiopia
killed 346 people including 18 canadians
a close encounter is expected in space
tonight and satellite tracking companies
are watching it closely too long defunct
satellites will whiz past each other
about 900 kilometers above Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania at one point it's expected
that two hunks of space junk could be
just 12 meters apart
that's according to calculations by a
satellite tracking company Leo labs and
here's why it matters they're traveling
at fourteen point seven kilometers per
second a collision would hurl hundreds
of pieces of debris into space
threatening other work
satellites scientists put the
probability of a crash at about 5% it's
predicted close calls like this will
occur more often in future as it's
cheaper and easier to launch spacecraft
now and Earth's orbit is getting more
crowded
Canada's soccer star christine sinclair
had solidified her place in history she
just set a new world record Sigler wide
open is it that goal against Saint Kitts
and Nevis is the Canadian captain's 180
fifth of her career and that means the
36 year old is now one goal ahead a
retired American striker Abby Wambach
who held a record until today recycled
racism still ahead the new corona virus
triggers an outbreak of old xenophobia
you are watching global national there's
much the experts still don't know about
the new corona virus and how it spreads
uncertainty can lead to fear and among
some people it's fueling a backlash
against people from Asia stereotypes and
racism are emerging and as Robin Gill
reports it's accelerated by
misinformation spreading on social media
Chinatown's in major Canadian cities are
already shrinking or disappearing
because of development and migration to
the suburbs the threat of a new disease
is hurting what little business is left
Terry - an activist is collecting the
disheartening stories people you know
are afraid that if they have a coffin
you see people just choking back their
costs because they're just afraid of
what people will think of them because
you are Chinese and people just keep
their distance from you the viral nature
of social media is exacerbating
ignorance surrounding the new
coronavirus calling it the Kung Fu flu
and suggesting it's a product of Chinese
food we are being singled out we are
being stigmatized
because of the corona virus it doesn't
help that a major Toronto newspaper
recently published this editorial
cartoon all this misinformation is
prompting health officials to call for
calm now I'm getting people telling me
you know oh my god don't go to this part
of Toronto because you know there's lots
of Asian people there that's how this
descends very quickly and that's exactly
what happened during SARS and none of
that is remotely helpful well this part
of the racialization of agents John Paul
Katanga Liz with the social justice
Institute he studied Canada's history
with a Yellow Peril recycling racism
against the Asian community when there's
an outbreak there has been kind of a
long-standing narrative around Canada's
vitality being threatened by the
presence of foreigners what happened if
something is coming from England we
racializing them as well Queeny chu is a
nurse who works with immigrants and
believes the rampant racism isn't
helping any Canadian I don't think we
should raise realizing this we
has where he came from that tendency to
blame comes from not knowing what's real
and what's false and tapping into
simplistic stereotypes isn't making us
more informed Robin Gill Global News
Richmond BC mission postable next
messages of hope from a Quebec classroom
to Australia the world is watched as the
fires that swept across Australia
devastated people property and wildlife
at least 30 people have been killed more
than 10 million hectares of land
destroyed and an estimated 1 billion
animals affected the scale of it is hard
to take in and so kids in one Quebec
classroom took a simple approach to try
to help and it's had a powerful personal
impact a mana jela wiki explains what
were some of the things that our friends
were saying in Australia most of these
young children had never heard of
Australia until their teacher told them
about the devastating wildfires was it
easy for people in Australia to have to
experience the fires it hit the grid one
and two children hard there's animals
that are dying the trees are falling
koalas are time to really sad and why
did you choose purple Amanda Donovan
teaches at this school outside of
Montreal her parents had a trip to
Australia planned and it sparked an idea
to make and send cards to firefighters
kindness has absolutely no limits and
when it starts with our littlest you
know just think of their lives and and
how much kindness they can bring I love
that you're using pencils and markers
the students made cards with messages of
hope inside I hope they get lots of rain
in Australia I hope animals don't tire
stuff like that this week
Donovan's parents visited Eden Australia
they hand-delivered the children's
letters to the local fire department the
fire department posted the story on
Facebook
Australians responded with dozens of
grateful messages
knew what where was Australia but now I
learned about makes me really happy and
I thought it was really special for the
kids to see how their gesture their acts
of kindness has an impact the
firefighters were so grateful they're
sending back goodies for the kids and
now they know they sent their love
around the world and it came right back
Amanda tell the wiki Global News
Montreal and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's York Canada is Slave Lake
Alberta we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at global
national calm and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
bye
[Music]
you